[Musica]
attenzione alla frizione perfetto so che
negli anni 90 vi schiantavate ma adesso
siamo nel 2022 attenzione al cambio Ok
Attenta attenta Attenta attenta Attenta
a te
mamma è una gang sono in realtà sono io
non riesco ad aprire
Eccomi Ciao bambini siamo qua in questo
abitacolo in compagnia del mio
istruttore di guida che mi sta aiutando
a non schiantarmi con l'automobile tutti
sappiamo benissimo che i giocattoli
degli anni 90 erano molto molto più
pericolosi di quelli di adesso e come
posso non comprare come ultimo episodio
di questa serie adesso che ho i soldi
gli sbullonati gli sbullonati sono un
giocattolo del dell'inizio degli anni 90
proprio precisamente il 1990 Nati dalla
scia del successo dei manichini dei
crash test che venivano usati nelle
pubblicità per mettersi la cintura di
sicurezza Quindi ci sta perché ti dicono
di metterti la cintura di sicurezza in
un posto dove li fanno gli incidenti
apposta
E da lì è nata questa fantastica serie
di giocattoli dal 1990 al 1994 quando
poi hanno detto sai cosa forse non è
proprio etico fare un dei giocattoli
dove tu devi schiantare le automobili e
fare esplodere i pezzi di Questi
poveracci e questo è uno di quei
giocattoli che nessuno dei miei cazzo di
amici aveva Io non l'ho mai visto dal
vivo potevo tenerlo soltanto ho delle
pubblicità delle televisioni o nei
negozi di giocattoli degli sbullonati
hanno fatto quattro serie e in mezzo a
queste serie C'era il famosissimo taxi
che è quello che ho comprato io c'era
l'aeroplano c'era la macchinina blu il
laboratorio dei crash test dove tu
testavi contro un loro muro le
automobili e gli omini del crash test e
li facevi saltare da una sedia mi sembra
un po' una tortura Anche perché poi
hanno creato il tavolo delle torture
degli omini del Cluster Questo vuol dire
che i bambini godevano molto di più nel
far saltare scusi le teste ai pupazzi
piuttosto che far schiantare le
automobili piccoli sadici bastardi e
posso dire se non c'è limite alla
decenza perché non creare anche cani e
gatti degli sbullonati cani e gatti e
così giustifichi il fatto che la
macchina esca dalla strada quando passa
un animale in mezzo alla carreggiata e
siccome non ci sono limiti alla decenza
perché non fare un bambino nel
passeggino degli sbullonati un bambino
morto tra le lamiere della tua auto e
sapete qual è la cosa più ironica
e tra l'altro questa serie ha avuto la
prima un successo così tanto grande che
volevano farci una serie animata in 3D
tanto che hanno fatto anche un episodio
ma poi non ha preso piede ed è rimasto
questo singolo episodio che si trova su
YouTube e ci hanno fatto anche una serie
di fumetti perché no voglio dire se
hanno fatto anche la testa che tu
schiacci e sputa l'acqua puoi fare
veramente quello che vuoi questa scatola
mangia gli occhi dei bambini Dio mio no
nel senso In senso buono è così ben
fatta che sembra quasi il frame di un
cartone animato Questo è il famoso taxi
degli sbullonati un'automobile che tu
poi schiantare contro il muro romperla e
poi come c'è scritto sulla scatola con
uno scatto torna intera c'è il tettino
di visibile cos'è il tettino cuscinetto
di protezione l'airbag le cinture di
sicurezza Mi raccomando molto importanti
il seggiolino ad espulsione Diciamo che
se tu devi fare un crash test per vedere
quanto l'automobile resista ad un
impatto mettere il seggiolino ad
espulsione abbassa la valutazione questa
cosa di una violenza fisica e
psicologica che mi fa paura questo
giocattolo apriamolo
è da montare ci sono gli adesivi Stiamo
qua fino a Natale bimbi c'è un manuale
di istruzioni in stile IKEA Ah no dai È
quasi Integra c'è un problema non ha gli
omini questo questo giocattolo ho speso
tutti questi soldi per il taxi degli
sbullonati e non ha gli sbollonati
dentro adesso Direi che non vedo l'ora
di schiantare L'auto è una cosa non fate
come lei non guidate bevete come fa lei
[Risate]
Però noi dobbiamo staccare tutto e
metterci gli omini non avendo gli
sbullonati per non schiantarla senza
nulla Abbiamo trovato un'alternativa
abbiamo direttamente dalla Playmobil
Danny Lazzarin e Favij che facciamo
guidare Danny e la cintura si mette
questo gioco È assurdo devo alzargli le
braccia ma ci sta Favij con un pezzo di
pizza in mano eh ricordiamolo Eccoli qua
Danny e Favij che viaggiano un po' come
Rick e morti parabrezza inserito e
L'auto è pronta sembra anche che abbia i
fari accesi siamo pronti per il primo
schianto tra l'altro è tocca farlo
contro questo palo devo essere molto
preciso 3 2 1 via
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ha funzionato incredibile Allora sono
partite le portiere e tutto il cofano si
è sfracellato le ruote sono andate Non
so una lì
Lorenzo è completamente volato fuori
dall'abitacolo Poverino L'unica cosa che
doveva saltare che era l'airbag non è
saltata benissimo lo so l'idea di questo
giocattolo può sembrare una follia è
probabilmente lo è perché sapete bambini
farvi giocare con un auto che devi
schiantare per divertirti potrebbe avere
ripercussioni sul vostro futuro però
quanto cazzo è stato divertente Io ho
una cultura cinematografica la cui base
è Bad Boys 2 è in baseball due ci sono
50.000 automobili che si schiantano
perché bimbi è quello che vogliamo
vedere la carne non così tanto non così
tanto però è stato bellissimo non posso
negarlo che poi immaginate bambini
potrebbe trasformarsi in una scena del
crimine questa cosa qua c'è un vigile
che con l'autovelox vede questi due
schiantarsi a 40.000 km orari dicendo Ma
questi sono due deficienti E allora
chiama la polizia arriva la camionetta
scendono questi due poliziotti un po'
confusi dicendo Ma quello è Favij e
Danny Lazzarin che sta guidando con i
manubri in mano che dice ho sbagliato
ragazzi Non vi dobbiamo arrestare non
c'è Che che avete combinato li fanno
salire sulla camionette li portano via e
lui è l'unica e finisce così questa
storia ma deliria parte bambini volevo
ringraziarvi volevo ringraziarvi perché
questa serie di un altro video con la
fabbrica di mostri Emilio con Ciro e con
gli sbullonati doveva essere un
tappabuchi E invece voi piccoli
malandrini avete dato un feedback così
positivo a questa serie che mi ha
sinceramente stupito e che dopo 16 anni
di canale io posso fare dei contenuti
come questo divertirmi e farli in modo
anche abbastanza semplice ed essere
ancora rilevante Grazie bambini per aver
visto anche le l'ultimo episodio di
adesso che ho i soldi
il trenino di Woody corre sui binari
ho sbagliato Sai invece Chi è che non
sbaglia mai io e In seconda posizione
invece c'è nordvpn Non fate come gli
sbullonati che hanno un sedile
iniettabile pensate alla vostra
sicurezza protezione da malware
protezione da pop-up invasivi ci sono
entrambe con la Tret protection
lui non ha usato nordvpn protegge la
vostra connessione se vi doveste
connettere a delle reti pubbliche per
esempio o per comprare questo splendido
libro sui mezzi di trasporto potete
connettervi ad un IP italiano e cercarlo
è proprio questo Mannaggia Per usufruire
degli sconti cliccate sul link col
codice Yotobi
[Musica]